so the Edward H humoral lecture is in
honor of dr. Hume and as May pause
many friends and for many years actually
the human family members are here with
us every year and dr. Hulme de voto
devoted much of his long and vigorous
life to work in China and elsewhere in
the cause of health care and medical
training he served as president of the
college of young China from 1923 to 1927
he returned to the US was and then
recalled to China in 1934 to work for
several years in liaison with the
Chinese national health administration
so from 37 times retirement dr. Hulme
directed a Christian Medical Council for
overseas work in New York
I wrote a number of books about medical
work on China and shortly after his
death in 57 funds when two colleagues
friends and family helped us establish
his fund and which is why we've been
able to invite the most eminent scholars
from East Asia from John Fairbanks in
1960-61 to Frederick mote and and now to
our speaker Tom Kristensen from Columbia
recently columbia so in any case i will
hand the floor over to peter
well it's a great pleasure to introduce
my former colleague at MIT Tom
Kristensen to give this lecture he's
done an amazing number of things both in
academia and also working for the US
government in the State Department he's
got his BA in history which I'm proud to
say we could almost claim him from
Harvard College an MA in international
relations from University of
Pennsylvania and a PhD in political
science from Columbia University in 1993
later he taught at MIT where we were
colleagues together for about five years
in the 1990s then he moved to Princeton
and has been there until this year and
now he's moved to Columbia where he's
professor of Public and International
Affairs and director of the China in the
world program at Columbia and he's a
tremendous Lee long CV with many many
articles and several books he's written
both for the professional field those
security studies in political science
he's written what I think classify is
even history analysis and he's written
articles for foreign affairs and the
popular press and many other things and
his most recent book the China challenge
I think everybody should read really
outlines the past 30 years or so of
foreign policy challenges in relations
between the US and China in a very
insightful way I just mentioned a few
things first actually his first article
was called threats assurances and the
last chance for peace the lessons of
Mao's Korea war telegrams in the journal
international security that's the first
piece of Tom's work I read and I was
very impressed by it again he gets a
historians gold star because new
telegrams that mal had issued in the
chemo Matsu crisis had been revealed and
he used the new sources from this kind
of information to create a new
interpretation of what mal was up to in
the 1950s and then useful adversaries
grand strategy
domestic mobilization and sino-american
conflict 1947 to 1958 is again a kind of
historical view of us-china relations in
this 40s 50s era as well as the
questions of grand strategies of China
and the US and how they interacted in
this period many many articles ensued
after that but his next look at least
the next one I read can't keep up with
all of times writing was what's worse
than a monolith Alliance politics and
coercive diplomacy in Asia this again is
a brilliant combination of political
science theory and historical analysis
looking at the fact that the u.s. had
allies during the Cold War in East Asia
and China of course had its ally for a
while Russia in the Cold War in East
Asia but the fact of having alliances
probably made the Cold War worse that
the fact that their lies had different
intentions from the superior partners
tended to heighten conflicts rather than
make them easier to solve and then
finally his most recent book the China
challenge as I said is based both on his
personal experience in the State
Department when he was involved in
negotiations as well as a very
insightful overview of us-china
relations during the past several
decades and I can't resist give reading
one little passage here which shows how
incredibly funny Tom can be in books
like this are not usually very humorous
but he has a kind of way of putting in
little dry pieces of humor that really I
think had a lot to the insight he was
involved in the rounds of talks the
six-party talks with North Korea and
China and others in 2006 and 2007 he was
sitting across the table from some very
tough negotiators from China and North
Korea and this is his short comment on
his impression of the North Korean
regime the North Korean regime was at
its core much more of a crime syndicate
than a legitimate nation-state the fact
that Pyongyang's entourage included one
sharply dressed and smooth
talking consigliere only heightened my
image of the North Korean regime as a
mob I had worked in the construction
industry in New York City in the 1980s
and had seen such characters before now
I give you Tom Kristen said to tell you
what you think thanks so much Peter and
thanks to Jing for having me and thanks
for to Elise for all of our help you
know hurting academics is never easy and
I appreciate all your administrative
support it's a great honor to be here to
speak for the humic at the hume lecture
here at yale university and i know your
speakers always say that it's a great
honor to speak at a university like yale
for me it's a particular honor because I
know you're very high standards having
failed to gain admission here for three
separate occasions and my brother went
here so you can imagine the the problems
that creates in the home front so it's
it's a great pleasure I'm gonna talk
about the rise of China and and national
security challenges for the United
States and its friends and allies in
Asia I'll speak for about 35 or 40
minutes and I'm hoping that we'll have a
lot of time for for QA I really see two
major challenges attendant to China's
rise in Asia and one of those challenges
is how to dissuade China from using
force or coercion to settle the many
sovereignty disputes it has in its
periphery and I will move to a map and
we'll talk about those sovereignty
disputes in a moment I think this
challenge is often missed by people who
see some other challenges and these
challenges I don't think are very
realistic and one is that they believe
China is trying to drive the United
States entirely out of the East Asian
region and the other is that China is
going to become a global superpower peer
competitor rival of the United States in
the vein of the Soviet Union
and I fit I see little persistent
evidence for either of these alternative
theories first I don't see a lot of
evidence that China has been adopting a
persistent strategy of driving the
United States out of East Asia if it
tried to do that there would be a very
dangerous conflict ridden strategy so I
believe that this is an imagined
strategy but it has not yet manifested
itself the second is I simply don't
believe China will be strong enough for
decades to be a peer competitor global
rival of the United States and we can
talk about that in the QA why I don't
believe you know China will be as
powerful as the United States is around
the world for a very long time so that
one you can just remove from physical
capability and the first one about
driving the u.s. out I think you can
remove because there's been no evidence
of persistent intention to drive the
United States out unfortunately the good
news ends there China doesn't need to be
a global peer competitor of the United
States to pose real security challenges
to US national security interests and
obviously even greater national security
interest to us friends and allies in the
East Asia region the region is very
important to the United States China has
long been capable of destabilizing that
region and China is more capable today
and it gets more capable every day of
destabilizing the region of East Asia in
ways that would great gravely impact
u.s. national security interests and
obviously again the interests of our
allies and friends in the region so
that's the first challenge the second
challenge I also think is often missed
and that is we need persistent
cooperation from China the United States
and like-minded states around the world
need persistent cooperation from China
to handle some of the global security
challenges that we face in particular
nuclear non-proliferation in countries
like North Korea and Iran and China's
economic footprint in these areas is so
great that it is impossible to put
pressure on these states without China's
cooperation that our China obstructs
those international efforts to pressure
those states those efforts are likely to
fail and there
even likely to fail if China does not
actively contribute because China's
economic footprint in those places is so
great and those states are able to rely
almost solely on the relationship with
China in times of dyers that you were
straights for those for those states
that would be Iran and North Korea in
particular in addition China has great
institutional power and international
institutions of all sorts especially the
UN Security Council where it has a veto
and that also requires the United States
to engage China on these international
security issues if the United States
wants to try to solve them short of the
use of force and that's something that
the United States does prefer to do in
most instances so China's role in these
issues is always very important okay so
let's look at the security issue number
one which is the need to dissuade China
deter China from trying to settle its
many sovereignty disputes in its
periphery through the use of force so
through the threat of the use of force
in ways that would destabilize East Asia
and East Asia particularly a globalized
world is extremely important to the
security of everybody so China has
disputes with several of its neighbors I
will roam out there is a dispute between
Japan and China Japan being the United
States most powerful and important ally
arguably in Northeast Asia there's a
second type of dispute in Taiwan it's a
little bit different it's about what the
sovereign meaning of Taiwan is in
relation to mainland China it's not the
same kind of dispute as the one above it
and it's different from the third
dispute that I'll talk about which is
the South China Sea and China's claim is
something like this the nine dash line
and it has disputes with Vietnam with
Malaysia
with Brunei with the Philippines and not
really a dispute with Taiwan because
Taiwan's traditional claim goes back to
before the founding of the People's
Republic of China and it is pretty much
the same claim so there's an overlapping
claim with with Taiwan so if you look at
the pictures of these things I'll just
show you quickly here is the do you sink
aku dispute we can read it in the Q&A
and then if you look at the mess that is
the South China Sea
you can see China has the most expansive
but they're not alone in having
expensive claims if you look at for
example the Vietnamese claim how far
that comes off of Vietnam and how much
it overlaps with the Malaysian claims
and the Filipino plays so the most
expansive in its claims in the South
China Sea
so try it the United States and and the
United States partners China's neighbors
need to convince China that those
sovereignty disputes should not be
handled to the use of force or coercion
in order to maintain the peace and
stability of a region that is very
important to the United States this has
become more difficult over time there's
been a very fast-paced growth in the
Chinese economy as you know going back
to 1978 and the reform period launched
by dong shopping in late 1978 but
there's been an even faster growth in
China's military modernization
especially since 1999 China's military
has grown very quickly in its
capabilities and its budgets in ways
that pose new challenges to the stage
and stability that I'm trying to
preserve and in this in this discussion
so let's look at China's traditional
military and what changed China's
traditional military was a military that
had two purposes both related to the
same core security interests and I want
you to focus on that as we move forward
in the discussion it's two purposes were
to counter the Chinese military that
People's Liberation Army is not a
national military it is a party military
that's not just a foreigners analysis
that's something that President Xi
Jinping insists on pretty much the
military to say remember you are a party
military we don't have a national so
because that was the main purpose of the
Chinese Communist Party's military wing
the PLA they didn't require a lot of
power projection capabilities for
decades so they had a large land army
designed to put down domestic foes and
to drown in a sea of militarized people
in addition they had a relatively
rudimentary nuclear force and public
reports are accurate just a couple of
dozen intercontinental ballistic
missiles liquid fuels most likely with
the warheads not made it to the missile
so very slow in response not something
that could take out the nuclear arsenals
or the superpowers but something that
would make the nuclear superpowers have
to think twice so that was Chinese
military for a very long time into the
1990s for the most part but more
recently China has developed the ability
to project power off of its coasts into
these disputed areas and China is
rubbing up against its neighbors and new
ways part China is is projecting power
and rubbing against its neighbors in new
ways as all rising powers do and lest I
may seem to be making a kind of cultural
argument saying that China is somehow
more destabilizing than other rising
powers I say this that in 2000 I
published an article with my colleague
at Columbia dick Betts in which we
argued that if China's rise in its
region is as destabilizing as America's
rise in its own region in the late 19th
century we're all in for big trouble
because the United States as you know
got into a totally unnecessary war with
Spain because of domestic jingoism and
nationalism ended up in a large
counterinsurgency war in the Philippines
all unnecessary and all highly
destabilizing so we can only hope that
China does better than the United States
I'm not picking on China but this is
what happens when countries rise in
their region they rub up against their
neighbors and new ways and the
capabilities and I'll list some of them
because I think they are important to
understand the capabilities that China
has developed to project that power
include the following their asymmetric
capabilities
asymmetric in the sense that they're not
closing the gap with the US military
power overall and it's in a significant
way but what they're doing is posing
risks to forward deployed US forces and
particularly to US allies in East Asia
if they were to get involved in a
conflict with China particularly in a
conflict with China muscies that china
believes it cares about more than the
United States and perhaps some of those
neighbors okay so the first type of
capability that I'll talk about are
accurate conventionally tipped
solid-fuel ballistic missiles this is a
real innovation for the Chinese military
there really was no other military that
ever created such a thing in the past in
any kind of quantity and what this does
is it puts at risk for deployed US bases
and if public reports are accurate the
DoD's public reports are accurate China
has developed and innovated an anti-ship
ballistic missile that can be fired from
the mainland of China and hit moving
targets at sea which reduces one of
America's traditional great advantages
of power projection far from home which
is naval aviation aircraft carriers if
you can't send aircraft carriers safely
toward a target you now have reduced
power projection capability unless
you're willing to pay very high costs
and as you may know on one aircraft
carrier there are 5,000 US personnel so
that's a big target in terms of cost a
second capability or submarines China
has invested in diesel-electric
submarines that it has acquired from
Russia
the former Soviet Union it has reverse
engineered some of these it has
developed them so that they're
relatively quiet and can say submerge
for a long time and those submarines are
capable of launching sophisticated
torpedoes laying sophisticated sea mines
and most recently launching cruise
missiles from below the surface of the
water in ways that again don't match the
US military but put at risk a superior
US military if it were deployed in the
Reid
China cruise missiles that are very
sophisticated are also capable of being
launched from the air and also from the
surface of the sea advanced aircraft
fourth-generation aircraft and
relatively large numbers that can fly
off the Chinese coast and put at risk
places like Taiwan the Japanese forces
around the Senkaku Islands and somewhat
into the South China Sea a little bit
less so into the South China Sea but
what's also often missed in these
discussions is China has sophisticated
air defenses that can set a kind of
umbrella off the Chinese coast and make
it very difficult for superior
militaries like the US Air Force to
project power without relatively high
costs in the vicinity of China
another capabilities anti-satellite
weapons one of the great advantages of
the US military in recent decades has
been the ability to control and see
enemy and friendly forces on the
battlefield in real-time it's called
c4isr and military speech speech so a
lot of that capability of the United
States has that that elegant capability
is reliant on satellites and China has
demonstrated its ability to strike
satellites from the surface of the earth
with anti-satellite weapons and
therefore potentially undercut some of
that superiority that the United States
has we all hear about cyber as a
potential tool in the military sphere I
take it extremely seriously well I can
say about cyber as somebody who still
has government clearances is that the
more you know about cyber the less you
can say about cyber so I'll just say
that cyber is another area where
asymmetric capabilities have to be taken
very seriously by a rising country like
China
then there's nuclear monetization and I
want to spend a second on this I talked
about the rudimentary nuclear deterrent
of China in the past and that was those
liquid-fueled missiles with warheads
that were not necessarily mated with the
missiles that would take a long time to
to launch them this left Chinese
strategist nervous about the ability of
a country like the United States or the
Soviet Union and its successor state
Russia to eliminate the Chinese nuclear
deterrent before it could be fired so
they modernized the nuclear deterrent in
a certain way they created solid-fueled
mobile nuclear-tipped missiles I say all
those adjectives for a reason that I'll
return to in a minute they also have
developed and if public reports are
accurate can now field submarines that
carry nuclear weapon submarines that can
carry nuclear weapons and I focus on
that for a reason so none of this is
domination by China over the United
States this is not China taking over the
world and I don't believe it's a new
Cold War with China and we can talk
about that some people in the United
States believe it is a new cold war with
China but it's not a new cold war with
China in my opinion but in some ways I
would say it's more complicated in terms
of course of diplomacy for the United
States and its allies it's more
complicated than the Cold War was at
least for the period from the Cuban
Missile Crisis to the end of the Cold
War and the reason is that the Cold War
was nasty we shouldn't be nostalgic
about it we shouldn't look back on it
with any kind of happiness it was a
nasty thing I'm really glad the
anti-communist forces the anti Soviet
forces in the Cold War one I think it's
a hugely important thing for the world
but in some ways the Cold War was
relatively simple after the Cuban
Missile Crisis in that both camps in the
Cold War knew where the lines were
between the camps for the most part
there were exceptions like places like
place like West Berlin and it's not
coincidental that those replaces have
lots of crises but in general you knew
if the NATO forces went into the Warsaw
Pact countries that would be an
offensive very aggressive act and that
the Warsaw Pact
went into the Western European NATO
countries that would be a very offensive
and aggressive act and we know from
human psychology that this type of
situation where there are clear boundary
lines between potential adversaries that
this is a hugely stabilizing factor
particularly in a world with nuclear
weapons because we know from real social
science and there isn't that much real
social science that's really science
right this is really science this is
psychology proven in laboratories by
Nobel prize-winning psychologists
including my Princeton colleague Daniel
Kahneman that shows that people across
ethnic groups across gender across age
groups have something in common with
rare exception and that is that they
will take bigger risks and pay higher
costs to defend what they see is a
legitimate status quo what is what is
legitimately theirs then they will to
get new things right this has been
proven there are exceptions thank god
they are exceptions like Hitler but they
are rare and the reason this is so
important for what I'm saying today is
that unlike in the Cold War after the
Cuban Missile Crisis there is no
accepted status quo in East Asia that's
why I spent the time I did describing
those sovereignty disputes it is my
strong impression from talking to
diplomats from all the dispute in
countries including Japan including the
South China Sea dispute members
including all factions in Taiwan none of
whom want to become part of the PRC that
all of them believe that whatever
position they take on sovereignty is
legitimate in other words they're
sincere and that's what worries me most
I wish they were lying I wish they were
assertive I wish they were revisionist
but they actually believe it that's true
for the Philippines that's true for
Malaysia that's true for Vietnam for
sure and it's true for China
they all have stories that say why their
claims illegitimate this is extremely
dangerous because it means that one
actor can be acting out of what that
actor believes is a defense of
motivation and therefore be willing to
take lots of risks and pay a very high
costs and the other actor can see that
actor as aggressive and revisionist and
needing to be stopped and that's why I
believe the East Asia coercive
diplomatic environment is more
complicated than it was in the Cold War
after the Cuban Missile Crisis so some
people tell me that they think China is
revisionist as trying to expand its map
in the South China Sea and they
surprised them sometimes and I say I
wish they said why would you say you
wish because if I believe that China
didn't actually think its claims in the
South China Sea were legitimate I
believe it would be easier to back China
off of those claims it would be easier
to deter China from those claims but I
do believe they have a historical story
about why those rocks reefs and islands
are theirs and they're sticking to it in
addition there are escalation risks I
listed those military assets in detail
for a reason one of the great advantages
that the United States has had one of
the great freedoms that the United
States has had in the post Cold War era
is that it was able to prevent its
potential or actual adversaries from
harming for deployed US forces in a
conflict by taking very aggressive
action against the capabilities of those
States to hit for deployed US forces
very early in a conflict that's how the
US military has rolled in the post Cold
War era in the Balkans in Iraq in Libya
or anywhere echoes and it's a very
aggressive process
the problem is that never before has the
United States had to try to implement
such a strategy against a large nuclear
capable state like the People's Republic
of China and were still China has put
much of its conventional deterrent
against for deployed US forces those
road-mobile solid-fueled conventionally
tipped missiles that I described on this
same and those submarines on the same
spines as the nuclear deterrent the
road-mobile solid fuel of modernized
nuclear deterrent and the submarines at
sea so if the United States were to go
on a campaign against Chinese missiles
to protect the forward deployed US
forces against a conventional attack
from missiles or submarines it's quite
possible the Chinese leadership would
see this as an attack not just on the
conventional forces but also on their
nuclear deterrent with real potential
escalatory results China does have a no
first use policy on nuclear weapons
which could be a force for comfort and
stability in this situation but internal
writings that were not supposed to get
and I did not get in the US government
but got as an independent scholar
suggest that no first use in China is
more of a guideline than a rule in other
words they think about using nuclear
deterrence and nuclear forces sort of
get taking a nuclear attack first so you
can't take too much comfort in China's
pledged no first use policy in this
context if you're worried about
escalation the last problem is that all
regional powers including US allies like
Japan and the Philippines who are parts
of these disputes and even Taiwan which
is a security partner of the United
States but not an ally are hugely
dependent on the Chinese economy for
their own economic well-being which
gives China quite a bit of leverage with
US allies including South Korea
say on this score and that's an
important factor as well
finally there's domestic politics and my
take on Chinese domestic politics and
these security issues is a simple one
I'm willing to defend it and that is
that since the financial crisis of 2008
the Chinese government has a combination
of reactions to that crisis and that
combination of reactions to that crisis
is very detrimental to the u.s. and
allied efforts to maintain stability in
Asia and it goes something like this
since the 2008 financial crisis the
Chinese government has been more
confident about China's prospects abroad
in East Asia and Beyond because it feels
like China's relative power has grown
quickly in comparison to others and the
Chinese government has been less
confident and more worried at home since
the financial crisis of 2008 and since
I'm a political scientist we love to buy
two tables and in this case the sell
that China has been in since 2008 is the
worst sell in the two by two table more
confident abroad more worried at home
because the worry at home can play
itself out in nationalist nationalism
and it can play itself out in the need
to react harshly to the actions of
others in these disputes and China isn't
always the one that initially picks the
fight sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
but it feels a need to react in a way
that doesn't make the government lose
face and in addition there's this
confidence that says these historical
disputes have to end and they have to
end on our terms we've claimed these
things for a long time now we can do
something about it so that's a bad
situation as well and before I make you
totally depressed about the sovereignty
disputes I will say one positive thing
which is there's a very positive feature
which I believe has helped keep the
peace and I think it's important for
Americans in particular to recognize
that it has been a force for peace and
that is there's something different
about the 21st century East Asia than
there was in great power
Titian and power transitions in the past
and that is a very deep degree of
economic interdependence products aren't
so much made in one country anymore
they're made in multiple countries China
is the endpoint for a transnational
production chain that involves lots of
different countries including other
disputants in these disputes China has a
huge disincentive to destabilize the
region for this reason by prosecuting
its claims violently or coercively and I
do believe that these factors have been
very very important in keeping the peace
it's not something you can prove because
it's a counterfactual but unfortunately
largely because of the behavior of the
two largest powers first China and I
want to emphasize that first China since
the financial crisis has adopted a
series of economic strategies that have
undercut the deepening of that
transnational production chain and
globalization and more recently the
Trump administration has adopted
unilateral tariffs that could do harm to
that transnational production chain so
now you have the two biggest powers
adopting policies that are challenging
this factor which is difficult to prove
has been a force for peace but I find it
hard to believe that the the disputes
that I've described to you between Japan
and China between China and the
Philippines between China and Vietnam
would not have already become much more
violent than they are if it wasn't for
this factor so I worry greatly that that
factor could go away but it won't go
away overnight and it's still there and
it's very very deep so it's a positive
force for peace in the region
the fact that products are made in by in
with parts from multiple countries in a
complex and very fragile transnational
production chain okay so that's the the
first challenge and the second challenge
the second challenge
let me say something about the US
response all right as China grows it
grows its capability to get out into the
region off of its coast
the United States has some really
difficult choices to make different
different types of challenges in
different areas around these these
disputes the one thing the United States
in my opinion needs to do is to maintain
a very strong military presence in East
Asia and it needs to maintain very
strong relationships with its allies and
security partners which is America's
greatest advantage over China in a
competition the United States has 60
plus allies and security partners
China has North Korea may be Pakistan
may be Zimbabwe may be Sudan a kind of
rogues gallery and if the United States
can maintain its security relationship
to its alliances it should be in a good
position to compete
I worry somewhat about our management of
our alliances in recent years and we can
talk about that in the QA I think that
the US should strengthen the situational
awareness the ability of different
countries in the region to see and the
ability the military capabilities of
some of the regional actors who actually
have a dog in the fight over these
sovereignty disputes when the United
States really doesn't and I think the
u.s. can assist in that process of
strengthening their capability to create
an asymmetric challenge for for deployed
Chinese forces but at the same time and
I think this is important and I hear
more and more voices in the United
States arguing in a different direction
I think the United States needs to stay
out of all of these sovereignty disputes
with the exception of the sinh kaku
dispute with Japan and the DIA dispute
from the Chinese perspective which has
traditionally been subject to the
us-japan alliance because the United
States gave those islands back to Japan
in the early 1970s administrative
control of them so the u.s. doesn't take
any position on the sovereignty in that
dispute but does recognize Japanese
administrative control because the
United States gave it to Japan other
than that the United States takes no
position on the sovereignty of Taiwan it
doesn't recognize it as part of China or
not part of China thinks no position on
that and it takes no position on any of
the island disputes in the South China
Sea including the Filipino claims it's
an allied claim
it simply demands that the disputants
solve the problems peacefully and in a
way that's in accordance with
international law and I think that's a
position the US should maintain I'm
hearing lots of voices of people saying
we should put Marines on features held
by Malaysia or Vietnam or or the
Philippines and it seems like a science
fiction and be really bad strategy to me
I think we need to stay out of that
because it's unnecessarily provocative
to the Chinese the United States needs
to continue to operate in the South
China Sea in every area where
international law allows these things
are called freedom of navigation
operations in many instances that call
Phan ops for short these things are not
particularly provocative military
activities there are some of the least
dangerous military activities imaginable
they're simply an assertion that we can
travel there and you can't stop us
without wanting to fight us the problem
that's happened in the past during the
Obama administration in my opinion is
these relatively mild military
activities were were flaunted in the
press as great muscular activity of the
Obama administration to stand up to
China which is totally ridiculous from a
military perspective and really bad
diplomatically because you're poking
China in the eye in public for no reason
you should just travel there the Chinese
will know you're there they can see you
and if your allies need to know you just
tell them we're traveling in that area
China's not keeping us out we can still
operate in the South China Sea and
elsewhere in ways that are legal and
they're not going to stop us so we
should continue to do that okay I
promised that there was a second
security
challenge and that is China's the need
for the United States and its friends
and allies to get cooperation from China
on global security issues like
non-proliferation the problem here is
that the world as I said before is more
globalized and more interdependent than
ever before in ways that are not similar
to the world before World War one or any
world we've seen before and as such
all major economic actors need to
contribute to pressure campaigns against
target states that are endangering the
international community if a country the
size of China does not contribute to
such efforts those efforts are likely to
fail if China obstructs those efforts
they're even more likely to fail and
China is by far the biggest economic
partner not just of North Korea which
most most people know it is by far the
biggest economic partner of Iran and
that's going to become a big issue over
the next year in my opinion China is not
only the biggest purchaser of Iranian
energy it is also the biggest supplier
of foreign consumables to Iran and it's
involved in the banking sector
infrastructure etc Chinese economy is
big enough even though it's still
technically a developing country per
capita income nowhere near that of the
United States its economy is big enough
to provide support and succor to any
state like Iran and North Korea enough
to survive an international campaign so
if we look at North Korea China I firmly
believe does not support North Koreans
develop North Korea's development of
nuclear weapons now if you have a
different view of that then you're not
going to follow everything else I say
but I dealt with the Chinese on this
issue and I don't believe they want
North Korea to develop nuclear weapons
but they also don't want to see regime
collapse in North Korea for a range of
reasons related to Chinese Communist
Party legitimacy at home and its
international strategy that I can talk
about in the Q&A China doesn't want the
North Korean regime to go away and it
certainly doesn't want to participate in
the destruction of the North Korean
regime China knows it has tremendous
leverage over the North Chinese
diplomats will routinely say we don't
have that much control we don't have
that much influence that's a very
convenient out because China doesn't
like its current situation that it knows
North Korea is totally dependent on
China and at the same time it's unhappy
with North Korean behavior and doesn't
want to take the steps
stop that behavior so it's a very
uncomfortable situation it's a big
burden on China if you talk to Chinese
elites particularly off-the-record they
will complain about North Korea greatly
they don't like this burden they would
love to take the burden off their
shoulders and give it to the United
States you take care of North Korea you
solve that problem just don't cause a
war in the process and don't destroy the
regime in North Korea but you take care
of it get it off our agenda so for the
United States to get no China to to
pressure North Korea and I've seen this
while I was in the government and I've
seen it since it has to do two opposite
things both of which are difficult for
American presidents to do and one of
those things is to make the current
status quo situation seem so dangerous
to China that pressuring the North
Korean regime seems more desirable than
letting those trends continue in the
same direction and that's a difficult
thing to do the best way to do that but
it's dangerous best in the sense of
effective is to make a credible threat
of war on the Korean Peninsula if North
Korea continues down its current path
because China knows it doesn't want a
war on the Korean Peninsula you know is
up here right and it's neighborhood and
it knows the result of such a war will
be its outcome that it's trying to avoid
which is the destruction of the North
Korean regime so that's a double bad
outcome for China and it's something
they worry about a lot but short of war
the United States can suggest to the
Chinese that if North Korea continues
down the current path the United States
and Japan will do new activities in the
military sphere that run against China's
long term security interests the United
States and South Korea will do things in
the security sphere that will run
against China's long-term national
security interests and worst yet Japan
and South Korea might start to do things
together in ways that would challenge
China's long-term security interests one
of the things China has prevented is a
current sort of NATO type encircling
alliance in its region and the US has
had a series of bilateral alliances and
China knows that it's unnatural for
Japanese and South Koreans
you cooperate in the security sphere
because they don't like each other right
let's put it simple they don't like each
other because of history so it's very
hard to accomplish but on occasion this
actually happens North Korea is so
obnoxious that South Korea and Japan
start to cooperate with each other
China notices in every every instance of
this and it's my personal opinion that
the reason China was so upset about the
deployment of theater high-altitude air
defense systems in South Korea fad was
not because those systems looked into
China but because they would be linked
to Japan in real-time in a way that
would create a kind of quasi technical
alliance and that would be a very bad
outcome for China so the problem for the
US on this score is it's very hard to
credibly threaten the use of force on
the Korean Peninsula because it's so
dangerous not only do you have the
30,000 US military personnel in Korea on
any given day you have about 250,000
u.s. citizens in Korea that would need
to be evacuated and unfortunately the
geography of the situation is South
Korea has put the majority of its
population and it's most expensive
assets and Seoul right up against the
enemy and that's where the Americans
live - now there's also the South Korean
allies you have to worry about all the
Koreans who would be killed that would
be very difficult so it's very difficult
to do that and it's very difficult to
sustain ROK Japanese cooperation so
that's a real challenge so the United
States needs to have that kind of
credible threat to get China interested
but then it has to do something that's
even harder for an American president to
do at the same time which is to assure
China that if it pressures North Korea
the end game of that pressure campaign
from the American perspective is not the
destruction of the North Korean regime
but merely the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula in other words if North
Korea were to denuclearize the United
States would have to credibly convey to
the Chinese that the United States can
live with the North Korean regime into
the future if it doesn't have nuclear
weapons that's even harder for the
United States to credibly convey it is a
bipartisan
- of the United States to overthrow
regimes we don't like it's not just the
George W Bush administration that I
served right in Iraq the Obama
administration if anything did it more
frequently in Ukraine in Libya what it
was the first Obama administration
strategy in Syria when the Civil War was
it was escalating there Assad has to go
that's regime change so the Chinese have
difficulty believing that the United
States would stop at denuclearization
and not overthrow the regime now well I
say all that because I think the Trump
administration in the lead-up to the
June 2018 Singapore summit handled this
situation
extremely well they were able to convey
both of those opposite threats and
assurances in a credible fashion because
of the unused unusual nature of the top
leader in the United States arguably in
that he looked like he might actually go
to war and real security experts in late
2017 including myself were very very
concerned about the prospect of war on
the peninsula given the trend lines that
we were heading on and the US military
was exercising very actively for such a
war the Chinese noticed this and were
quite concerned in addition the Trump
administration has had a studied
projected indifference to the lives of
people outside the United States as a
kind of foreign policy ideology in a way
that lent credibility to their frequent
claims that they were not seeking regime
change in North Korea to the contrary
they were showing videos to the North
Korean leadership about how great their
country would be without nuclear weapons
and how wonderful their situation would
be to the point where the president said
he has a kind of love affair with the
dictator of North Korea this is
something that most Americans couldn't
imagine right but it's a certain
characteristic so they were able to
convey those two things we're not about
regime change and we are willing to go
to war and lo and behold what did the
Chinese do put the maximum pressure that
they've ever put on North Korea in the
Lee
to the Singapore summit without which I
don't believe there would have been a
Singapore summit but the good news story
ends there because I think at this
Singapore summit my own personal opinion
is the administration and perform
terribly by declaring victory in a way
that was self congratulatory saying
we've solved this problem let's move on
to the next one they removed all the
pressure on China and allowed China to
finally take that burden off his
shoulders and give it back to the United
States and say okay you guys work it out
and if the Trump administration's own
claims are correct and I'm sure there
they are because it fits logic the
Chinese reduced that pressure markedly
as of Singapore to the present now
there's not as much pressure on North
Korea to denuclearize to negotiate in
good faith on denuclearization as there
was before the summit so I think that
was a real tragedy because they built up
that leverage and I think they may have
squandered it in that process so I give
them very high grades on the lead-up to
the Singapore summit and I give them
very low grades on the on the Singapore
summit itself I don't have time to talk
about Iran in detail but a lot of the
same dynamics apply to Iran if China
doesn't cooperate with a pressure
campaign on Iran I would expect pressure
on Iran to have very limited effect
because of China's very large economic
footprint in Iran and I expect this to
become a very big issue in us-china
relations in 2019 there's a six-month
waiver right now on what the Americans
call secondary sanctions order secondary
sanctions the sanctioning of third
countries for having good relations with
a country the United States doesn't like
the Chinese with some good legal
argumentation believe that such
sanctions are illegal they don't like
them they think everything has to go
through the UN Security Council but the
United States likes these things it
helps reach the first Iran deal in in
2016
and it is a potent tool for the United
States as the holder of the world's
currency etc that's lots of ways to hurt
banks energy companies etc through these
secondary sanctions now China's gotten a
six-month waiver from the Trump
administration I don't expect that to
last and I think it's going to become a
big issue in the us-china economic
conflict in 2019 when the United States
starts to sanction Chinese banks energy
firms over their relationship with Iran
and it seems like the administration has
a pretty open-ended strategy towards
Iran to just hurt Iran as much as it
possibly can without any kind of clear
delineation of what Iran needs to do and
not do to get out of that pain so I
expect that to last a long time I expect
it to be a major irritant in us-china
relations and I expect that to be on top
of and an aggravation to the existing
us-china trade war that's going on in
2018 so I've spoken for too long and I
would love to hear your questions and I
would love to be disabused of any form
of pessimism that I have and I would
love to be bolstered in any form of
optimism that I have so please thank you
for your attention and looking forward
to your questions
[Applause]
all convinced yes thanks for a great
talk I just started your your talk with
describing the buildup of the missile
forces especially the intermediate-range
by China lethality accuracy and quantity
that made me think of the INF treaty
with with us with Russia
what are you use on the abrogation of
the INF treaty using the China angle as
a as a justification okay so it's a
two-part question so I'm going to break
it down into pieces I I'll just show my
own cards I've been a long-term advocate
of withdrawal from the INF treaty in
most immediately because Russia has been
in systematic violation of it for quite
a long time it is a basically a
bilateral treaty between the Soviet
Union the former Soviet Union and the
United States it is actually a
multilateral treaty now because a few of
the Soviet successor States are signed
on it prevents not intermediate nuclear
forces it has a terrible name it does
not actually address nuclear forces per
se it is a ban on certain types of
missiles because during the Cold War was
considered easier to spot and count
those missiles than it was to figure out
what kind of warhead they had on them so
it bans land-based missiles with a range
of 500 kilometers to 5,500 kilometers
for Russia and the United States were
all intents and purposes Russia has been
in systematic violation of that for
several years we've complained to Russia
about it they've told us to go away
right and what it does is it allows
China this space to dominate those types
of systems in East Asia without a
response by the US so I didn't
understand the logic I have a lot of
colleagues who believe that arms control
is like religion you never violate it
because it's you know part of the 10
commandments of international relations
I just I think arms control is a tool it
could be a potentially it could be a
potentially stabilizing tool it could be
a potentially destabilizing tool it's a
tool and it was a tool that was
extremely useful the INF treaty was a
very good treaty that the Reagan
administration and Gorbachev signed for
the time it is now outdated so I think
it's a good idea that the u.s. now has
options in that realm to build
conventionally tip systems that could be
based in Guam or it could be mobile and
based on US allies in the region so I
think that's a pretty definitive answer
that I think yes we should get out of it
but whether it's all about China if
Russia had had abided by its agreement
then you'd have a bigger cost for the
United States to pull out in other words
it would be the u.s. saying we're gonna
unilaterally violate this we don't care
about our commitments and that has that
has side cost that are eliminated in
this case because Russia has violated it
systematically for you do you think just
as you described how President Trump has
been somewhat unique in terms of his
capacity to project attitudes that
otherwise wouldn't be credible do you
think that's true with US allies in the
region as well and do you think that his
administration has yeah potentially
permanently changed our relationship
with allies permanent permanence a long
time so no but I do think that the
downside is some of this bluster in 2017
I don't want take his bluster because I
think they were serious I really don't
want to say it's bluster I think they
were very serious about getting ready
for the use of force but I think it's
scared allies a lot even Japan which is
probably the most hawkish on this issue
of the u.s. regional allies
was nervous in late 2017 that there
might be a war that the current North
Korean missile ranges clearly ranged
Japan so you know there's always talk
about them developing an ICBM do they
have an ICBM but would it work
but everybody thinks they have the
ability hit Japan so Japan was ready to
start a war and we're gonna be on the
target zone there so they wonder South
Korea was very nervous I was in South
Korea in December 2017 there's lots of
nervousness there so yeah it has it has
its impact particularly in the case of
South Korea now that you have a
relatively I don't know what adjectives
to use because every adjective you use
is judgmental but he's more
accommodating to the north and his
predecessors let's just say that it's
more accommodating to the north and his
princess so to have a very hawkish
policy while you have a leader like that
in South Korea could have strains on the
us-rok relationship and I worry about
the us-rok relationship moving forward
because it seems like president moon is
a very energetic and ambitious force in
the region now that he's going to
continue to push forward with this
accommodation strategy my guess is the
Trump administration is going to become
sick and tired of North Korean foot
dragging and want to go back to pressure
that's going to lead to some friction
so yeah this there a cost for sure and
um you know I think that again I I'm not
you know I hope it comes across I'm not
trying to take sides I'm I'm an
independent I served in a Republican
administration I'm not a Republican I
was a White House appointee in a
Republican administration but I often
say I'm a Groucho Marx estai would never
join a party they would have me as a
never um so when I when I congratulate
the Trump administration on that
approach to Singapore I think it was
smart to want to talk to the North
Korean leadership and I think it was
difficult to arrange and I think they
did a good job getting there and then I
think somewhat predictably it didn't go
very well
character flaw no it really is I really
believe that all these problems are
solvable well no there's two things I
don't think the you know I don't think
China has demonstrated in its policies
and its doctrines and the writings that
the public's publish and the writings
that we get even though we're not
supposed to get a systematic set of
doctrinal strategies that suggest they
want to drive the United States out of
East Asia
that's just East Asia right in other
words destroy the us-japan alliance
destroy the us-rok Alliance I think they
might be happy if that were to occur but
I think they know how dangerous would be
to try to do that and therefore they've
more moderate and they're just saying we
have to live with these alliances and we
have to figure out how to counter them
make them less likely to come after us
but they haven't done that in terms of
global power projection and global
dominance I just simply don't think
China has the capacity nor will it have
the capacity to compete with the United
States for decades to come and one of
the things I raised her with people is
you know everything we talk about in
terms of especially military affairs
with China is right up against China you
know we talk about well how can we
prevent China from dominating this area
how can we prevent China from dominating
this area how can we even touch China
from forcing unification with Taiwan all
this stuff is right up against China no
one ever says you know China will soon
be able to take over Puerto Rico through
amphibious assault and the US military
can't do anything about I mean it'll be
laughable to even consider but that's
the equivalent of what the United States
is dinner by projecting power that far
away from the United States and trying
to help its friends and allies
farawayfromhome something I support I'm
not criticizing it as imperialism or
anything I'm just saying it's very
difficult to project power that far from
your home base against it determined and
increasingly powerful adversary even
though that adversary is not a peer
competitor so I wrote an article in 2001
called posing problems without catching
up to try to get away from this too
in the United States about just how many
decades at we can't take China to catch
up and I said China can already spoil
our whole day and that's only gonna get
worse over the next you know two decades
and unfortunately I was right I just
don't see them economics in diplomacy as
60 plus US allies and and security
partners China's got very few and in
economics I don't see them anywhere near
the United States in terms of economic
power and in military affairs they can't
project power very far out of their
region and not be a severe risk to
relatively weak militaries let alone the
US military we're going with my question
was you know Xi Jinping has talked about
by 2050 China being a global leader I
liked your translation a global leader
because that's how I translate it not
the global leader some people translate
it as they want to be the global hegemon
well good luck with that
right it's hard to be the global hegemon
it's tough being an American national
security tech but um
yeah I think they'll be a lot stronger
in 2050 of trend lines continue that's a
big if there's a lot of challenges for
China so will they be the in a sense
already are a great power in that we
can't solve any major significant
problem around the world as I suggested
without Chinese cooperation so even if
China has a per capita GNP in 2012 in my
book I had nine thousand dollars a head
the US was fifty six thousand dollars a
head so that's real economic power as
cheap per capita GNP because that's
disposable income um but it's got so
many people that's a big economic
footprint that you can't ignore so if if
will China be a major economic and
political player in 2050 yes so Xi
Jinping is almost certain to be right
unless it has a catastrophic collapse
and I'm still of the opinion that a
catastrophic collapse in China would be
a catastrophe not just for China but for
the United States there's no office in
the State Department for catastrophic
collapse in China
there's no office in the Pentagon for
catastrophic collapse of China think
about the implications it would be mind
blowing
it would make Syrian refugee crises look
like you know a picnic proliferation oh
just it's so people should be careful
what they wish for when Americans say we
no should undermine the Chinese system
and destabilize it we should promote
reform because that's the right thing to
do and it's also the smart thing to do
for everyone including the Chinese but
we shouldn't be undermining stability in
China in a radical way because it's
dangerous Jing I keep thinking about the
point you made a beginning much i
standed that china does not have the
intention of keeping us out of East Asia
but certainly South China Sea right how
would you talk a little bit about the
blue water Navy yeah we'd overhaul of
American defense strategy and also
China's to build up East you know
aircraft carriers and so forth okay so
China is now able to project power out
into the South China Sea it gets more
and more tenuous as it gets further and
further from home for the Chinese one of
the most important aspects of military
power projection is always logistics the
ability to get water and food and
ammunition to your forces far from home
the US military has become really expert
at this over a long period of time the
Chinese military is just learning how to
do it so it has a lot of power
projection in this area it has less less
less less less and remember that claims
go all the way down to here so what
China has done because the neighbors are
relatively weak it has not only used its
what's called gray hull Navy it has used
Coast Guard ships what are called white
holes and something that the Chinese
have invented the maritime militia which
are basically fishermen with guns who
answer to the government and they travel
to these areas to assert Chinese
presence in ways that are very annoying
to relatively weak navies like
the Malaysian Navy or the Filipino Navy
that aren't very annoying to the US in
addition they've built these artificial
islands in the South China Sea in the
Spratly Islands has disputed Spratly
Islands in a way that I have to I'll
admit I was surprising to me the scope
and speed with which they did it was
surprising to me and I assumed right
away that they would be militarized
President Xi promised that the President
Obama that they he had no intention of
doing that of course I didn't believe
him at the time and he has gone ahead
and militarized them um that's a real
challenge particularly for the other
disputants in the region it's not a
particularly US military in a fight if
there was a open fight between the US
military and the Chinese military those
Islands would be a very bad place to be
being in a fixed area in the 21st
century with military equipment out in
the open with no place to run really
really bad right so but if you're a
Filipino you have to take those things
extremely seriously
and it does provide them certain
capabilities which means you have to
take them out they pose a threat if
you're tasked to take them out you have
to escalate so it does provide that
coercive leverage
and it's a problem but I don't believe
that China is going to be able to
exclude the US military from the South
China Sea in the near future and that's
really what the whole dispute is about
from an American perspective it's not
about freedom of navigation for shipping
so when people testify to the Congress
they say five trillion to seven trillion
dollars of goods and owned really knows
how much a lot go through the South
China Sea it's the busiest trading route
in the world so it's really good show
for a congressional testimony to say
whoa you know we have to protect the
global Commons and keep the trade
flowing through that China is never
gonna cut off trade through the South
China Sea most of that trade goes to
China why would they cut it off right so
what's the real issue it's freedom of
navigation for the US military the US
military has a network of alliances
around the world it projects power
through this region into the Middle East
the US has basing rates in Singapore
when we fought in distant Afghanistan
some of the earliest bombing runs we
know from public reports I have to speak
like that because I do government work
um public reports that some of those
bombing runs came from Singapore to
Afghanistan this is how the US projects
power around the world if those links
are cut by an actor like China it would
have severe implications for us
alliances so the US needs to operate
there I don't think China can prevent
the United States from operating in the
South China Sea and if it tried to we
would have to open fire on the US
military which is a degree of Chinese
aggression that I don't expect to see
but when we do operate there we
shouldn't be poking the Chinese
government in the eye in public because
it's pointless
it only gets their backs up it only puts
them at their face and at you know on
the table in front of their own public
just to operate there if they object we
object if they don't object we just make
a blanket statement that we operate we
the United States operate wherever
international law allows and we will
continue to do so and no one will stop
us and it's not a good bet to take on
the China US Navy to this day it's not
as strong as it was compared to China in
this region but it's not a good bet it
wouldn't it wouldn't end well the
Japanese Navy is pretty formidable I
wish the Filipino Navy was more
formidable I sometimes worry that our
allies want to fight to the last
American
I I don't know how close they are I
don't know how to gauge the closeness of
their relationship I think any country
dealing with the United States right now
would want to build the impression if
not the reality that the top leader in
that country gets along personally with
our president because he seems like a
very personal istic president so that's
something China's conveying you know
that President Xi and President Trump
had this relationship
president Trump constantly praises
President Xi and maybe that's his
diplomatic strategy realizing that
President Xi has built up this kind of
cult of personality around himself in
China that hasn't existed for a very
long time so if he's that kind of leader
then you want to brush him up and say
what a great leader he is and how
wonderful he is so maybe that's the
mutual thing but I don't know how close
that relationship actually is I don't
put a lot of stock in that for solving
the problems but it is one ray of hope
in a pretty dismal environment and again
I do think that the trade disputes
started with the financial crisis China
changed a lot of its economic trajectory
after the financial crisis in ways that
ran against long-term trends that were
very beneficial for China and very
beneficial for the region of sort of
positive some economic relations with
its neighbors and that has aggravated
lots of countries the United States and
during the Obama administration
it's aggravated the EU it is aggravated
Japan and South Korea and then in more
recent years the United States has moved
away from its long term commitments to
multilateral institutions in ways that
has a grated lots of people including
China so now we're in a very dark place
if the answer to this problem is the
very good personal relationship and a
wonderful piece of chocolate cake
between President Xi and president
good on them Who am I to say I'm not the
president it's way above my pay grade
but what concerns me is that the Trump
administration has used the threat of
tariffs or tariffs or the willingness to
scrap previous agreements in ways that
have allowed them to gain leverage with
other actors in order to deepen the
economic integration between the United
States and those actors that's how I
would code the relationship with Canada
and with Mexico in other words a lot of
it was leverage now I don't think the
NAFTA was the worst deal ever actually
it was a good deal and I don't think the
current deal is world's better than
NAFTA but it's better than after from an
American perspective somewhat better and
it was created through that leverage
that threat of tariffs so that can be
done that way and I think that that was
at least the goal of some of his
advisors I think my sense is I don't
know because I don't know that your
excellent question might Trump no pun
intended all of these factors that I'm
about to list but I don't think that
that's true for China I think there's a
domestic ideology about China and trade
with China that is bipartisan it is held
more strongly in the Democratic Party
than in the Trump administration but
there's this idea that China has been
cheating us and they need to be punished
and we need to decouple to some degree
from the Chinese economy and I think
that there is on top of that ideology
I'm an ideology I don't fully agree with
I hope it's I'm suggesting but but it's
very real I mean if anybody was the most
protectionist in the in the 2016
campaign was Bernie Sanders by a lot
second was Trump and third was Hillary
Clinton who said she would pull out a
TPP you know my you know my hope was
that if she were elected that she was
just lying again so so um so I think she
might have actually stayed in TPP
somehow but TPP was pulling a TPP was
bad so I just think with China in
addition to the idea ideological issue
is the national security one which is
that the notion that the integration
between the US and Chinese economies has
led to some of
as military modernization that I
described and accelerated that military
modernization so that's a winning hand
in a domestic dispute because there are
certain advisors of the president who
really don't like the us-china economic
relationship writ large so normally in
this kind of economic dispute that we
have with China the solution of most
administration's from either party would
be to try to remove the obstacles that
you see I think the Trump
administration's complaints about the
Chinese economy are legitimate in other
words they have moved from 2008 to the
present in a more statist direction away
from the trends up to 2008 they have
forced foreign companies to give up
intellectual property as a precondition
for access to the market they have
stolen intellectual property through
systemic efforts so all of that was true
even when I was in the government some
of that was true back before the
financial crisis but it's gotten much
worse all those things are real but then
the question is what do you do about it
are you trying to remove those obstacles
and create greater integration or are
you trying to are you trying to just
punish China and decouple and if you're
trying to remove them what you do is do
things like bilateral investment
treaties multilateral investment
treaties to try to remove those
preconditions for economic integration I
think that's true for the Trump
administration in Canada I think it's
true in Mexico my sense is it's not true
no I'm not sanguine I'm not confident
but if there is progress it'll be for
the reason you said it I thought was an
excellent question
it will be because Tom Kristensen
doesn't have a clue what's in the head
of the president the United States or in
the head of the president of China and
their relationship and maybe they can
just solve this problem but if they do
some of president Trump's advisers will
be kicking and screaming because they
won't like the result the result would
be what most presidents in the United
States would want which is to remove the
obstacles remove the theft protect IPR
integrate the economies more along the
lines that they were doing from 1978 to
2008 but some of his advisors people
like Peter Navarro
I would think wouldn't be happy with
that result right so I don't know but I
think if there is a solution to the
current trends we're on and I'm
pessimistic that there are it will be
along these ones that the top leadership
will say get my advisers out of the room
we're gonna cut a deal it's possible I
have two questions one is about nuclear
weapons in North Korea and the other one
is the terminal high altitude so there's
general consensus that there's no way
that North Korea will give up nuclear
weapons I don't think they have this
copán capacity to produce like a dozen
each year um is there any possibility
that we recognize North Korea as a
nuclear power and then negotiate with
the country that's the first questions
my second question is you mentioned the
child is not concerned about its
security as a result of these the
installation of the terminal high
altitude defense system but more
concerned about the collaboration
between Korea and Japan could you
elaborate a little bit about I can't
really elaborate more about it but let
me just say what I can say about it is I
have a student who's a Navy officer who
worked on missile defense in the past
he's published about it in the
Naval War College review you know his
name is Robert Watts and I would I would
recommend that you read his article I
agree with his thesis I agreed with his
thesis before he wrote it I agree with
his thesis now I can't elaborate on the
technical side of it because most of
that stuff would be out there out of the
realm of public discussion but missile
defense is very complicated it requires
a lot of situational awareness and a lot
of linkages and it seems natural that
Chinese security analysts and they've
written about it are concerned about the
implications of such sophisticated
missile defenses in the hands of any of
the regional actors if they wanted to
keep those regional actors from not
being linked to a global US network
Japan's link to that global in the u.s.
network so I'll just leave it at that
I could really can't go into more detail
I apologize there are limits to what I
can discuss so so the question of North
Korean Dino cars ation I never give up
hope on these things I think you have to
continue to push with North Korean
denuclearization my boss Chris Hill and
the six-party talks one time said
something that's stuck with me and I
agree with which is North Korea with
nuclear weapons I would rather see a
toddler with a hand grenade it's just
not it's not a good state to have
nuclear weapons
so is it impossible no I don't believe
it's impossible I believe that it's
become a kind of truism that it's
impossible to get for them to give up
nuclear weapons because they believe it
is there their security blanket their
their last type of security right well
there's another security blanket that
they have which is China without China
they don't have security their regime or
anything else and they know it so I
still believe that if China were willing
to put on persistent and heavy-duty
pressure on North Korea that they would
have little choice but to negotiate now
whether they would negotiate in good
faith or not as another matter and I
think they did negotiate in June 2018
because China put pressure they
negotiated in February 2007
outlining in my book because China put
pressure on they notice when China puts
pressure on and if you ask a Chinese
diplomat I guarantee the Chinese to
promote say Oh America exaggerates our
control over North Korea it's not a
question of control it's a question of
reminding them what's keeping them alive
so if it became totally intolerable to
China now could you just recognize North
Korea as a nuclear state a legitimate
nuclear state and then negotiate why I
don't understand why I mean they
violated their NPT agreement they pulled
out of the NPT and nobody believes they
should have them if you recognize North
Korea as a legitimate nuclear state and
then negotiate I don't know if you
gained any negotiating leverage because
it looks more acceptable for them to
have them and I think in addition you
significantly raise the likelihood that
South Korea will go nuclear and I
believe that Japan will eventually go
clear I know that Japan has allergies to
nuclear weapons and I take them
seriously but people get over allergies
right there are pills for that
so so and I don't think that's a good
outcome for anyone is Japan really gonna
be the only country in East Asia forever
that doesn't have nuclear weapons so I
think it's in China's interest to get
these weapons out of there right the
question is what price are they wanted
to pay and how many risks are they
willing to take and again you know I
gave the Trump administration high marks
it's not easy as an academic to give the
Trump administration high marks in the
spring of 2018 to get North Korea to the
table and their willingness to talk
which I always think is a good idea
people your engagement strategy with
China was a failure stop engage that's
just idiocy
we had an embassy in the Soviet Union
during the cohort you engaged when you
can now I don't think we should
recognize North Korea and have
diplomatic relations without some
progress on this but you get my drift
just you know it it doesn't help to just
isolate nicely
can you speak louder another hand
there's also clear military and economic
expansion when it comes to PRI literally
building islands and I was wondering you
talked a little bit on in which sectors
China is on the defense and in which
sector is there looking ok I think China
has been very assertive and
destabilizing ly assertive in the South
China Sea so I want to make that
statement upfront and I think the
building of the islands was very
retrograde behavior by China now to
Chinese defense just as a side note is
that China was the last country in the
dispute to build artificial islands in
the South China Sea it's just that when
China does stuff it really does stuff
it's a big no these are giants you know
coral killing enterprises right and they
build much bigger assets on those
islands so they were days when I say
they think they're defensive what I'm
saying is China believes it's securing
long-held claims that they believe are
justifiably Chinese from history I think
that's true in the East China Sea I
don't know a single Japanese he doesn't
believe this in kaku's or Japanese I
don't know that many Chinese who don't
believe the Diu Islands should have been
returned to China in the Cairo
declaration of 1943 and therefore are
being illegally occupied by Japan no
one's there not occupied that's the
great thing about this in cockers and
why I'm optimistic South trying to see
not that many people down there people
are the ones who cause trouble so
they're just rocks and reefs and stuff
sing Kaku Islands no one lives there
they're just goats on the Senkaku
Islands just goats and you know I
actually do these like gaming exercises
sometimes and before I had clearances I
used to do them and and you know one
time they said you know you're the
Chinese leader you have special forces
on one of the one of the Diu islands
that to start the game what's your first
move I said I get my Special Forces off
of that
they weren't happy with that because
it's crazy to try to occupy these sharp
rocks because how do you get water to
people you know they're so easy to
attack them it's not good to be in a
fixed position at sea so all that said I
think China has been very assertive
destabilizing in the South China Sea by
being as assertive as it has been visa
via the other disputes but the problem
is that I do believe at the same time
that they believe that sacrificing their
claims there would be the loss of
something that there is committed to
defend because they have made those
claims for so long and I think that's
true the Philippines I think that's true
of Malaysia I think that's true of
Vietnam for sure for Vietnam and that
worries me all these people believe
they're in the right and when people
believe they're in the right they tend
to be tougher right so this is a bigger
challenge of the United States
fortunately the United States doesn't
have any claims and when it does the
freedom of navigation operations it's
just saying we can sail and fly here you
can't stop us it's legal that's all the
United States is saying it's not saying
we're siding with Malaysia over some
shoal against China and I hope that
stays that way there's no need for the
United States to do that it would be
very provocative for the United States
to do that and it's entirely unnecessary
but I hear more and more voices in
Washington saying we need to take a
tougher stand and it usually takes the
form of the Obama administration was too
weak
usually the sentence starts with the
Obama administration was too weak we
need to be stronger I'm like well what
what what did the Obama administration
do or not do that you object to well
they didn't stop the Chinese from
building the artificial islands they
said well how were they supposed to stop
them from doing that should they have
used the US Navy to shoot dredging ships
from China usually silence after that
question well they didn't see it coming
I said I kind of think they did dredging
ships are big there are satellites right
I don't have to disclose secrets to say
I think they saw I come right maybe in a
political sense they didn't know in 2013
that China was gonna go on this binge
but I think they saw it have very
difficult to stop unless you want to
take sides and say no you're invading
the fill
penes claim and so the ruling in 2016
was very useful it was a sweeping
victory for the Philippines it was a
sweeping condemnation of the Chinese
position I think that's the basis on
which the US can operate and other
actors can operate just to say China's
never clarified what this means in
international law and they're very
reluctant to do so it's one of the
things the United States has insisted
that China do because it would be
illegal to say all of that water inside
that red line is Chinese territory water
that's rich is ridiculous impossible
under international law now they could
say that all the rocks and reefs and you
know things that stick out of the ocean
are Chinese and that they have certain
international rights but the
International Tribunal has said there
are no islands in the southern part of
the South China Sea in the Spratly area
so therefore there are no exclusive
economic zones cast from those features
so China's claims even if they got all
the spots would be relatively limited
and the nine-dash line would be largely
meaningless so the courts have said the
nine-dash line itself is not consistent
with international law in any meaningful
way and certain activities and actions
by China in the nine-dash line have been
illegal and one of them is the building
of a structure at mischief reef in the
1990s on top of what's called a low tide
elevation and they built a military
structure on that on that low tide
elevation in the Philippines easy cast
from its main islands which is
indisputable easy the problem is that a
low tide elevation is not sovereign
territory low tide elevation is
something that is not above water 24
hours a day when it's high tide its
submerged so that doesn't count in
international law for either territory
territorial seas or economic zones and
you can't just build on top of a low
tide elevation and someone's exclusive
economic zone without permission and
China never got that permission so
that's illegal
we know that one's illegal that's one of
the freedom of navigation operations the
US has conducted recently is really
close to that saying you got nothing
a China freaks out and it says things
that are legally ambiguous like you are
threatening our sovereignty what does
that mean we violating it or we
threatening it if you're violating it
that's a claim I'd be clarifying Claire
you're threatening it I don't know what
that means
so yes China has been assertive I don't
want to dismiss all that I'm very
concerned about Chinese behavior but I
would be more concerned if I thought I
be less concerned if I thought China was
doing something outside of his long-term
claims because I think we BL the
backward now if China started to suggest
that it was gonna move on Okinawa I
would find that concerning but I think
we could stop it it wasn't part of the
map around which country around the
world oh yeah let's go back okay so
China has invested in ports around the
world it has had some political
implications of those port purchases so
one of them was in Greece oops
so up in Greece at Piraeus it has
99-year rights
this might sound familiar to those who
know Chinese history 99-year lease
rights to a port in Sri Lanka so it's
hot China's own Hong Kong and it has
invested in ports throughout Europe
fairly large holdings so a lot of people
have made a lot of fuss about this trend
the port you mentioned before Gwadar
here it's a it's important because it's
important because it will build a can
potentially build a path into China that
avoids this alleged Malacca dilemmas
ability of Germany to be cut
straight amok amalaki dilemma i believe
is a large fabrication of various forces
in china that benefit from the story of
the malacca dilemma putting construction
companies who work out here
people who build pipelines through Burma
and the end the Chinese Navy all of whom
benefit greatly from the story that the
United States is going to shut off the
Straits of Malacca and keep things from
flowing into East Asia which would also
damage our allies and anyway but that's
just that's a side story so is it
important yes it's important in that it
gives trying to influence in these
regions in the in the case of Greece
Greece as a member of the European Union
European Union wanted to raise a human
rights complaint against China which has
dismal human rights and worsening human
rights conditions particularly under Xi
Jinping and lo and behold China had this
investment in Piraeus and Greece blocked
the EU for making so that's the kind of
influence that China's gotten it's not
how it's often portrayed in the US media
I don't think it's China trying to
systematically undermine democracy
around the world it's China
systematically trying to prevent the
rest of the world from criticizing
Chinese economies party rule at home
which is a much more limited operation
it's a much more achievable operation
and I think it's a different type of
operation than the systematic targeting
of democracy which I do think the
Russians have done quite a bit of right
which is a different bag of beans so so
is it important the general story is
that this will provide power projection
for the Chinese is also djibouti right
there's Gwadar there is Srilanka that
this will provide the power projection
for China around the world it's going to
take a long time at a minimum for China
to have the Navy that could exploit
those assets people point out that there
is a Chinese Navy flotilla off the coast
of Africa but that is it a
counter-piracy operation it's very
limited in its military fighting
capacity to build the kind of Navy that
could use those ports in a kind of US
style way is
many decades away at least a few at
least a few in addition having port
rights in a sovereign country does not
give you control of the port lots of US
ports are run by foreign companies I
learn this stuff it's stuff they force
you to learn as a China specialist so
lots of US ports in California elsewhere
are run by foreign companies because
they're good at it it doesn't mean that
in a war the United States couldn't get
those people out of there it doesn't
mean that the US Coast Guard doesn't
have sovereign policing rights in those
ports so that's true even for Sri Lanka
weak Sri Lanka so I worry a little bit
less about it until I see more evidence
but it's something to watch fortunately
it's easy to watch and it's slow-moving
so we should keep an eye on it but I
don't lose a lot of sleep over it yet it
is something to consider the whole one
belt one Road initiative which is really
interesting I think has been greatly
exaggerated
and it's and its importance to date my
strong sense of it is having study the
1950s in China
Peter I mentioned my book my first book
is that this is largely a political
campaign at this point the great leader
has said everybody needs to be involved
in one belt one road so everybody lo and
behold is involved in one belt one road
so no matter what you want to do
internationally you've got a link it to
one belt one road and I'm not convinced
that there is a great grand blueprint in
anybody's head about where this is all
heading and if there is I'm not
convinced that the actual activity of
Chinese entities has fit that grand
blueprint there's some very good report
very good report from CSIS on the one
belt one Road which says let's imagine
there is a grand strategy here and what
that it fits what President Xi has been
saying where would you expect the
activity to take place in which
countries and in which areas of those
countries and he kind of tracks the
geography and the lo and behold it
doesn't seem to be following it and I
talked to one professor who said yeah
you have to be part of one bill we
wanted to hire some guy who knows
something about Central Asia just
because he's a good scholar so we just
said it's part of
one belt one Road initiative and lo and
behold got funding for for the house
this is what political movements and
communist countries are like let me let
me take is there a woman who wants to
ask a question
guys tent it's it's it's a it's a it's a
tenancy in every every place I go okay
so this will be the last one but I
wanted to make sure you know because
thank you guys guys thank you for so
this is more of an intellectual exercise
you might stop me but why why do you
think is China more interest more inward
looking or more interested in protect
more interested in holding on to its own
territory or holding on to its
historical claim and expanding overseas
or projecting strength of the seeds
because you you mentioned that Russia
seems to be interested in sort of
toppling democracies or undermining yeah
democracies overseas but why is is China
not doing this I'm just curious is it
it's China not at the stage of economic
development yet or is it just a
particular function okay it's a great
leaders it's a great question I have to
preface my answer with saying I'm not a
Russia expert right so I don't know what
makes Putin tick I do think that the
reason that China is focused on its
current territorial claims is in part
because they're near China and that's
where China has the capacity to project
power now that could change over time so
if those ports became real naval bases
and China had a real blue water Navy
with all the logistics supplies all the
bells and whistles and could project
power into the Indian Ocean and it's a
significant way for a significant period
of time I would be concerned and be
watching that but it's also part of the
nationalist story of China and the ccp's
domestic legitimacy that it was going to
rectify the unequal treatment of China
in history going back to the opium war
Chiang kai-shek
also had that ideology as part of his
legitimacy in the kmt regime of the
republic of china so there's a domestic
reason to emphasize the historical
claims as well
and what is Russia do what it's doing in
part Russia is much more of a at the
current leadership in Russia as I
understand it is much more of a kind of
wounded recent victim than China in the
sense that they lost their Soviet empire
relatively recently and they feel like a
lot of it was negotiated away either
unfairly or by their immediate leader in
the post-soviet era who was a drunk and
there's no doubt I mean Yeltsin was
drunk all the time 24 hours a day he was
drunk it's hard to imagine right a great
power the leader liked but he was drunk
all the time so so for Putin's
perspective things like Crimea were
simply given away right and back in the
days when they were Putin as kritis
critical of Khrushchev for giving Crimea
into Ukraine as part of the Soviet Union
right which is the initial sin but back
then nobody imagined Ukraine would ever
be independent so it didn't matter that
much right but that's once it's
independent why don't you get it back
well the argument is and I don't know if
it's true what the arm is because
Yeltsin was drunk so they have stuff to
get back they have irredentism right the
question is how much does that expand
does that mean all the Baltic states
yeah Estonia Lithuania laughs you have
to become part of Russia again that was
really scary those are NATO allies that
would be trouble and then I think that
Putin is much more aggressive in a kind
of Soviet way about interference in the
internal affairs of other states and his
desire to discredit European Western
European democracy and the EU because he
sees that as part of the NATO expansion
that's coming at him I don't think China
has that same set of concerns and the
Chinese Communist Party I don't see them
as revisionist I don't think they're
trying to overturn the international
order as we know it they're routinely
called revisionist I actually think
they're quite conservative I think the
United States has long been revisionist
in a way that I support
the United States has tried to promote
democracy around the world where there
is no democracy this is something I
support right but that's revisionist I
think the Chinese Communist Party is
about one simple thing in the post mail
era when Mao was in power they
interfered at everybody's internal
affairs so never believed a Chinese
expert or diplomat assess China never
interferes in the internal affairs of
those states Mao did it every day in
every way but since Tung Shao pain took
over the Chinese Communist Party has
been all about the Chinese Communist
Party all three words right that it has
to be Chinese
it's about China it's about domestic
it's about one-party rule and it's about
a communist party rule in the 21st
century which is simply bizarre right
it's a 21st century I just went to
Prague I just returned from Prague two
days ago I went to the communism Museum
it's weird that China has a communist
party you said if you take a step back
there aren't that many left it's kind of
embarrassing it should be kind of
embarrassed they have a communist party
it should be kind of embarrassing it's a
21st century but they have won and so
does North Korea and so does Cuba and
they're sticking to it and they're
trying to make the world safer
authoritarianism in the sense that they
want them to have the world not be so
critical of Chinese Communist Party rule
at home that it's some how do you
stabilize it so they criticize color
revolutions abroad promoted by the
United States they criticize any
criticism of China's domestic rule and
they criticize things like China's
severe recent repression of the we Gers
in Xinjiang that's going to really
become a big issue this isn't something
the rest of the world's going to just
turn a blind eye to particularly the
Islamic world so I think it is going to
become a major agrement in China's
foreign policy and we'll see how it
plays out but I think what China will do
in each of those instances is try to
muffle criticism of China on that score
not
try to create authoritarianism as
opposed to democracy in the country
that's criticizing China on that school
which is a very different set of goals
it's a great question I don't I don't
hope the answer is somewhat satisfactory
I think it's a little bit too
complicated and I think you'd have to be
both an expert on Russia and China to
answer it more fully but I do see them
as different they are lumped together in
the national security strategy the
United States China and Russia are
revisionist States I don't think they
should be lumped together they're both
challenges but they're different types
of challenges at least to date thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]